- La décision va plaire
aux 260 000 Québécoises
qui ont signé cette pétition :
Québec facilite l'accès
aux hormones bio-identiques,
ces médicaments qu'on prescrit
pour soulager les problèmes
causés par la ménopause.
DRE SYLVIE DEMERS, Centre
ménopause-andropause Outaouais
- C'est une grande victoire,
c'est un très grand pas dans
l'accessibilité pour les femmes
qui en font le choix.
(indicatif musical)
- La Dre Demers, qui
a participé à la série
documentaire "Loto-Méno",
de Véronique Cloutier,
estime que ce type de traitement
hormonal a beaucoup à offrir
aux femmes ménopausées.
- Ce que montrent les études,
c'est que plus les femmes
commencent l'hormonothérapie
précocement, à la pré-méno
et plus elles le prennent
longtemps, plus leur espérance
de vie est augmentée
et plus leur qualité de vie
est augmentée.
- Les hormones bio-identiques
comme l'estradiol-17B en gel
et la progestérone micronisée
coûtaient cher.
- Le ministère de la Santé
a négocié une réduction
de prix avec les entreprises
qui les produisent. Désormais,
ces produits seront remboursés.
DRE LYNE DESAUTELS, Fondatrice,E
- Ça pouvait coûter entre 40 $
et 70, 80 $ par mois pour
une des deux hormones seulement.
Donc, je pense que ça va aider
énormément.
- L'utilisation de
l'h=>kOk
conventionnelle a baissé
radicalement après
la publication, il y a
une vingtaines d'années,
d'études qui faisaient état
d'effets secondaires importants
sur la santé des femmes.
La Dre Desautels considère
que la nouvelle génération
d'hormones dites bio-identiques
est plus sécuritaire et que
les médecins doivent en tenir
compte.
- Les médecins, on doit remettre
les pendules à l'heure en termes
de formation, d'éducation.
Que ce soit les médecins,
la communauté des professionnels
de la santé ou les patientes, ou
la communauté en tant que telle,
il faut commencer à remettre
le rôle des hormones
sur la bonne voie.
- Le ministère de la Santé
produira bientôt un guide
destiné à favoriser
une meilleure prise en
charge globale de la ménopause.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal